hi i'm emma chamberlain and these are my
favorite snacks
[Music]
first up we have cheez-its
i mean these are probably my favorite
snack of all time and within the past
few years the white cheddar have been
added into my obsession at first it was
just these and then one time i tried
these and it blew my
mind i'm just a big cheese girl i love
cheese it completely destroys my stomach
but it's probably one of my favorite
foods a cheez-it is just the ultimate
snack
there's nothing better when i first
moved to la
i didn't know
how to take care of myself and so i
would just eat like a box of cheez-its
every day throughout the day and that
was like my main food group
imagine i
these
[Music]
these are probably the most smash smash
all these are probably the most special
snack that we're gonna talk about all
day
this was
in my lunchbox every single day of
elementary school i kid you not every
single day my dad would pack a massive
like snack bag and i would refuse to go
to school if i didn't have these in my
lunch i actually haven't had one i'm
gonna open it
i haven't had one of these in so long i
forgot what they taste like
their chili lime flavor
i mean they're really delicious
i used to eat so many of them that the
flavor would build and then by the end
like my mouth was just like looked like
a raisin on the inside because it just
was so dried out yeah i need a dangerous
amount of these and people would ask me
for them the answer was always no like
these were my pride and joys
okay
[Music]
so
i'm not a huge candy girl but if i am
gonna have a candy
it's these these were always in the cart
i mean always and i would eat like one
of these every two days i used to eat i
don't think i ate any nutrients until i
turned like 15. everything i ate was
like processed to the max no regrets but
these are just so good they're not too
sweet they're so chewy these are the
superior candy choice in my opinion they
also made otter pop popsicles that were
sour punch flavor and when i tell you
that i would eat a box of those a day i
would eat a box of those a day
ah
this was like what i considered
nutritious as a kid it was madeline
cookies
oh
these are the most precious thing on the
planet like these are at almost every
coffee shop but nobody talks about
madeleine cookies like i don't hear
people being like yeah i want like a
madeleine right now this was always my
go-to you know like my parents would be
drinking their coffee i'd be having one
of these maybe six of these and they're
just so good they're kind of like they
almost have like a honey flavor to them
they're really moist
sorry if that word triggers you i think
that we should be past that though by
now these ones are like specifically
really golden brown that would have
totally made me freak out and get
excited as a young person not as good as
a croissant though
here come my boring snacks
[Music]
grain-free dairy-free nacho chips it's
like yes okay emma moved to l.a we get
it now that i'm older i think i feel the
effects
of food a lot more listen i still have
fun but like
this is a go-to
it's boring it's a little bit depressing
but but maybe it isn't you know what i
mean are they as good as a dorito not
even remotely [ __ ] close and if you
eat one of these and think you're gonna
get a dorito your day is gonna be ruined
but if you go into eating these you know
thinking like okay i'm eating chia seeds
and nutritional yeast in
a chip
then you might you know
be pleasantly surprised okay
i know you're thinking
emma shut the [ __ ] up why are you
talking about an rx bar on a snack show
like have a little bit more fun
i get what you're saying but these are
so
these are so good i
hate
bars
generally i don't really like them i
think that they're really boring and
they're a waste of a meal like it's just
like
not fun
but
the maple sea salt rx bar specifically
and pretty much only this flavor is
worth it i might try putting one of
these in the microwave i feel like that
could be really exciting
let you guys know how that goes
oh
justin's dark chocolate peanut butter
cups i mean you just can't go wrong with
a peanut butter cup i also love dark
chocolate when i was younger my parents
always were like when you're older
you're gonna like dark chocolate better
and i was like
shut up no i'm not i they were right
i now prefer dark chocolate obviously
these are great as a dessert but they're
also great as a snack pretty much
anything with peanut butter and
chocolate in it i'll eat though and not
complain this is my ultimate snack
spicy hummus
these crackers are great with the spicy
hummus but i will literally eat spicy
hummus with everything and anything
funny story before i came here i
postmated a whole tub of hummus
to my hotel i ate the entire tub of
hummus with carrots for lunch
very dysfunctional lunch but i have zero
regrets i i think hummus might be one of
my favorite foods especially like going
to a place where they make it fresh like
my mouth is watering talking about it
it's so good
so yeah but this is like my more on the
go
hummus situation and i'll eat this whole
tub in one sitting um easily
[Music]
all right that's it those are my
favorite snacks from my childhood and
present i hope you enjoyed also one of
my favorite things to drink with my
snacks is coffee and i have a coffee
company chamberlain coffee if you want
to check it out and in my opinion like
a coffee and snack
situation in the middle of the day
is like the best part of the day anyway
thanks for hanging out with me
[Music]
you